well the science is accumulating that we
can begin to scale back our mass
quarantine is particularly more
draconian elements of them without
disastrous risks to public health it
will always be risked people a long die
of this virus no matter whether we get
inoculations against it or not but we
can pull back a little we know that
because there is evidence of it pretty
much everywhere Sweden never lockdown
and despite what you have likely heard
Sweden is still no worse off than a lot
of Europe states in this country like
South Dakota Iowa and Arkansas did not
issue shelter-in-place orders ever yet
all three of those places were below the
national average in coronavirus cases
and in deaths Denmark in the Czech
Republic loosened restrictions and have
seen at this point no surge in new cases
so it's pretty clear that in many parts
of this country we could almost
certainly do the same and yet some
cities and states will not consider
doing this in fact if anything they're
moving in the opposite direction as the
pandemic appears to recede at least for
the moment their restrictions are
becoming tighter and that's when you
know this isn't really about public
health it's about making mediocre people
more powerful and there may be no one in
America more mediocre than the mayor of
Chicago Lori Lightfoot life had recently
announced that anyone who meets
privately with friends or even talks
about meeting privately with friends on
social media will be monitored and could
be arrested now I've directed
superintendent Brown to order all police
districts to give special attention to
these parties and this is how it's going
to be we will shut you down
we will cite you and if we need you we
will arrest you and we will take you to
jail period the time for educating
people into compliance is over
don't be stupid don't come out don't
advertise on social media we're watching
you do the people of Chicago take Lori
Lightfoot seriously how did it a fool
like that wind up in the mayor's office
Lori Lightfoot believes she has the
power to imprison
you if you talk about your weekend plans
on Facebook how did she get the power to
do that let's still not clear what is
clear is that Lightfoot has no intention
of following her own rules living by her
own restrictions we know that because
Lori Lightfoot recently broke her own
quarantine in order to and this is real
get her hair done she got caught when
her hairdresser blabbed about it on
social media but perhaps not
surprisingly she didn't seem ashamed in
the slightest
unlike you she explained Lori Lightfoot
has to look good I'm the public face of
this city I'm on national media and I'm
out in the public eye and you know I'm a
I'm a person who I take my personal
hygiene very seriously as I said I felt
like I needed to have a haircut I'm not
able to do that myself and so I got a
haircut I take my personal hygiene very
seriously I feel like I needed to have a
haircut the funny thing is you may be
feeling the same way maybe you take your
personal hygiene seriously too maybe
you'd like a haircut but are you Lori
Lightfoot okay
didn't think so so shut up and get back
to your smelly apartment stop
complaining and if you don't you're a
Nazi that's their new line which is only
their old line in fact it's always their
line disagree with them and you are a
Nazi and because they've now lost all
capacity for nuance they're actually
saying it out loud now over the weekend
CNN suggested that anti lockdown
protesters in Michigan were in fact
white nationalists very much like the
ones who marched in Charlottesville
famously a few years ago because of
course they are they're disagreeing with
the people in power must be Nazis
governor Gretchen Whitmer hastened to
agree with that assessment
some of the outrageousness of what
happened at our Capitol this week you
know depicted some of the worst racism
and awful parts of our history in this
country you know the Confederate flags
and nooses the swastikas the you know
behavior that you
Sene and all of the clips is not
representative of who we are in Michigan
so when you disagree with me says
mouth-breathing political hack Gretch
Gretchen Whitmer you're a Nazi and CNN
agrees because if there's one thing that
CNN cannot stand to see its descent
ordinary people disagreeing with the
proclamations of the mighty how is that
even allowed in fact just the other day
one CNN reporter wind on Twitter that
too many people were going to a park
that he liked so when New York police
swooped in to break it up that reporter
applauded how dare they it's my Park
over on CNN they celebrated the arrival
of Chinese drones in the skies over New
Jersey because what this country really
needs is more surveillance and hectoring
from the people in charge or as MSNBC
put it it's life saving Elizabeth New
Jersey is now using drones to spread the
life-saving message the drones make it
easier for police to see into certain
areas where access by patrol cars is
more difficult that includes tight
spaces between buildings behind schools
and in backyards you don't need to be
some crazed wild-eyed civil libertarian
with the goatee to find all of this
pretty distressing what's happening now
is unprecedented it's dangerous and it's
completely and unequivocally
unconstitutional it violates the letter
and the intent of the bill of rights on
many levels in some day soon we will
deeply regret letting all of this happen
if only we had someone now to protect us
as our rights disappear oh wait we do
the ACLU for more than a hundred years
the American Civil Liberties Union
fought for the civil rights of the
powerless which at this stage means you
you're the powerless so where's the ACLU
today well they're playing along with
the authorities they're sucking up to
power they're joining CNN and telling
you to shut up and obey as freedoms
vanish across this country the ACLU has
filed dozens of lawsuits not on your
behalf or on behalf of the Bill of
Rights but demanding
Meilin voting to a bet voter fraud
demanding the release of more criminals
in illegal aliens their website boasts
about this at length but so far it looks
like the ACLU has filed only a single
lawsuit in response to the mass
quarantine and it was in Puerto Rico
what's the message the message is the
ACLU is squarely on the side of your
overlords now that's a change meanwhile
our country and its centuries-old norms
are dying before our eyes
we could give you many examples here - a
Montgomery County Ohio authorities are
reporting a greater than 50% increase in
deaths from opioid Odie's addiction
rates not just to drugs but to alcohol
are skyrocketing from the data we have
so far that seems true across the
country and yet paradoxically at the
very same time cancer patients are going
without here's one indicator of that
mark the pharmaceutical company the huge
pharmaceutical manufacturer is
predicting a major hit to its earnings
why because its biggest cancer fighting
drug is being prescribed less often it's
not that fewer people have cancer or
they need it less it's they can't get
into the hospitals or they're too afraid
to they've been intimidated by
politicians into not getting cancer
treatments vaccines checkups major
surgeries all being delayed people will
die as a result of this in fact they
already are dying and that's fine
with the people in charge just don't
plan a dinner party on Facebook they'll
arrest you for that